yo como presidente de la república no
seré presidente de todo jefe de todo y
finalmente responsable de nada sampdoria
cuando se presentó a las elecciones
presidenciales francesas de 2012
joshua o'loan señaló una crítica ya
conocida el alcance de un presidente
francés es muy amplio quizás demasiado
amplio en francia el jefe de estado es
un líder versátil con varios sombreros y
algunos privilegios controvertidos como
comandante del poder ejecutivo nombra al
primer ministro y preside el gabinete
establece la agenda política de la
nación proponiendo leyes y si los
legisladores se interponen puede
disolver el parlamento u organizar un
referendo popular el presidente francés
es también el jefe de las fuerzas
armadas y por tanto tiene el poder de
desplegar tropas en el extranjero y
ordenar el uso de la fuerza nuclear el
mandatario representa a francia en la
escena internacional negociando y
ratificando tratados y supervisando el
cierre de acuerdos comerciales
estratégicos en ocasiones el presidente
puede serlo en acción física de la
política exterior francesa cuando
jacques chirac visitó jerusalén en
1996 su exasperación ante el fuerte
dispositivo de seguridad israelí se
consideró una señal de la postura más
pro palestina de francia que quieren que
vuelva a mi avión y regrese ya francia
eso es lo que quieren por encima de todo
el presidente tiene una última carta el
artículo 16 de la constitución le
permite asumir el control ejecutivo
total si la nación se encuentra bajo una
grave amenaza saldo gol quien elaboró
las drogas chivas del alto cargo restó
importancia a cualquier amenaza
porque quieren que empiece una carrera
como dictador a los 67 años los
presidentes franceses están en el centro
del poder pero tienen sus velas en cada
encierro de la política nacional